[Music]
super bowl of caring mobilizes ordinary
people to do extraordinary good in their
local communities
the super bowl of caring started 30
years ago in a church in south carolina
with one prayer on super bowl sunday to
be mindful of those who don't have a
bowl
full of soup to eat the youth at that
church
took that on as a as a challenge and
they asked the question what if
everybody watching the big game just
gave a dollar or one can of food
and if you look at that today that would
be a hundred million dollars in one day
executive director allison reese says
they've raised more than 163 million
dollars to date
a small organization with a large
network
due to the pandemic they began looking
at how technology can assist with this
year's efforts
they created the tackle hunger map you
use the search bar to find
charities in your neighborhood zip code
or city to encourage thinking about
giving locally through churches homeless
shelters pantries and food banks
and most people don't know where their
nearest food charity is
and that's something that we're trying
to address
using our map nobody just says oh i
think i want to open a food pantry that
seems like a good thing to do
every one of them will tell you how
difficult this world is
to manage and how difficult it is to
find the products that are needed
and how difficult it is when one has to
turn someone away
and doesn't have the product that they
need and right now many of our food
charities are having to do that
super bowl of caring doesn't deliver
food directly it acts more like a
catalyst
by infusing the money into the food
charities across the nation
and with next our nation's outreach this
year the nonprofit
hopes you will help raise more than one
million meals